okay people have been asking for me to
bring this back I did it a few months
ago people loved it I'm going to do it
again
I am doing book recommendations today
I've been reading a ton I was recently
on vacation and I read three books while
I was in Aruba
the david pakman show book
recommendation page is back david
pakman.com slash recommendations i'm
going to make a newfound effort to keep
it updated and you can now once again
this has been gone for years you can
support the david pakman show when you
buy the books I recommend using the
links at david pakman.com slash
recommendations by the way now I have to
be very careful in how I say this if you
click on one of the links at david
pakman.com slash recommendations and you
don't end up buying one of the books i
recommend but you buy something else
that also supports the david pakman show
I'm being very careful in the language
that I use all right
here's letter I'm gonna give you two
non-fiction books and two fiction books
I just finished this two days ago
American kingpin okay
the epic hunt for the criminal
masterminds behind the Silk Road it is
extraordinarily well written by Nick
Bilton I think I read this in three days
it's close to 400 pages I was so sucked
in by it that over the long holiday
weekend Labor Day weekend I read this in
like three days this book number one is
just a caper
of the highest level in catching Ross
Ulbricht the creator of the Silk Road a
dark web website on which firearms and
drugs were bought and sold it shows how
clever some people in law enforcement
can be and it also shows us the
dysfunction that exists between
different law enforcement agencies and
intelligence agencies you know we hear
oh they don't work well together this
book aside from just being extremely an
extremely entertaining read it sucked me
in from the first page it also shows the
dysfunction that exists between agencies
so get this one david pakman.com slash
recommendations american king pin the
hunt for the criminal masterminds behind
the Silk Road my second nonfiction
recommendation for you today is
plutocrats plutocrats by Chrystia
Freeland this is a book about without
making ad homonyms and without placing
too many value judgments on things it's
a book about the development and growth
of this sort of plutocratic over class
in American and world society it deals
with Oleg archetypes in other countries
it talks about Tax Policy it talks about
a lot of the different political and
financial elements that have led to much
of the inequality that we now have it's
not just inequality in terms of money
the book points out it's also inequality
in terms of access to education which is
related to money and other things ok
plutocrats by Christian Freeland david
pakman.com slash recommendations use the
links there to get it okay now to
fiction books a brand new one and then a
classic I read this during my vacation
in Aruba a couple of weeks ago delta-v
by Daniel Suarez this is much like
American kingpin is a real-life caper
this is a sci-fi outerspace sort of
caper it is an extremely interesting
book a lot of science in it which in no
way makes it feel like a slog in any way
the book moves I think it took me like
five days to read it of course I was
just sitting on the beach every day
reading it's easy to get through books
that way and it involves something we've
been talking about in the real world
which is the possibility of asteroid
mining in the future it is so well
written the science and it makes it
interesting and I could not more highly
recommend this book delta-v by daniel
suarez i tweeted about it the other day
and a couple people tweeted me pictures
that they had already purchased the book
that's a new fiction recommendation and
then an old classic fiction
recommendation I'd never read this until
a few months ago
The Count of Monte Cristo by Alexandre
Dumas this there are many versions of
this book of course it was not written
in English this is as far as I know an
unabridged oh no it is a translated and
abridged by Lowell bear this is a great
translation I recommend it it doesn't
it's not as long as some versions this
one is still 5
pages but it goes quick The Count of
Monte Cristo is just one of the best
stories that has been told period it's a
story of revenge it is a story of
entrepreneurship I would say it's just a
great book so all of these and many
other recommendations go to david
pakman.com slash recommendations use the
links on that page to get these books
and then you will be supporting the
david pakman show in so doing and also
if you by any of these books most
authors are now on twitter not alexandre
dumas been dead for a long time but many
authors are on twitter i recommend if
you get these books help the show get
attention in an organic way by tweeting
to me and the authors I bought your book
because David Pakman recommended it and
I'll do another one of these in a couple
a couple of weeks if people are
interested